do you think
i'm thinking about that kid with a
hatred do you think there will always be
hatred in the world do you think
uh from another perspective do you think
there'll be war
always is that a fundamental aspect of
human nature
or is that something we can escape yeah
so war i think has like very negative
connotations in terms of bullets and
bombs and death and kind of
just very morbid type um
understanding conflict on the other hand
i think people look at and say of course
there'll always be conflict right you
just can't have
billions of people all on the same
planet without some level of
disagreement whether that's a
disagreement of ideas
disagreement over physical you know
geography
or something else and so i think
conflict will always exist
the question is what form does war take
moving forward
and so in my mind you know it's starting
to look a lot more clinical
right a lot more drones a lot less
soldiers on the ground
a lot more use of special forces and
kind of these small highly specialized
teams rather than kind of big mechanical
armies
um and then you get into like the
information warfare and kind of cyber
warfare and you start to understand that
we're at war with a lot of people right
now right doesn't mean we're necessarily
dropping bombs
uh on their countries it doesn't
necessarily mean we're sending soldiers
there
but on a daily basis we are engaged in
these kind of you know
cyber battlefields and so if that's
where war starts to play out
it one changes the tools and tactics and
techniques that
we need to arm our country and other
countries will arm themselves with
but it also changes the way that we
think about war right
it see it sounds a lot less worrisome if
i say
hey we're going to go to war with a
country but by the way there's going to
be no death
right okay like that doesn't sound
nearly as bad as hey we're going to go
send 10
000 soldiers and you know some
percentage of them are going to die on
the battlefield and then we're going to
you know basically pipe back videos and
articles saying that american soldiers
are dying
yeah there does seem to be a fundamental
difference between the
the genghis khan style like if i would
feel differently
if somebody like hand to hand with a
knife
murder my family versus cyber security
why i stole
all their data stole all their money
stole everything they owned
falsified their identity all that kind
of stuff that those
are both traumatic events but
they do seem to be fundamentally
different but maybe that's actually very
narrow
style thinking because ultimately you
have to think about what is life and
what's happiness
and um it's like the samurai thinking
i'm not sure what's more painful if i
take it to myself like i'm not sure what
i would rather
live through being stabbed
like to death or
having my identity stolen all my money
stolen
or maybe reputation destroyed
like with lies or something like that
that that's very interesting to think
about if you think about quality of life
and all those kinds of things
well one that's finite right
yeah and the other is kind of a long
prolonged almost torture physical pain
versus psychological pain
uh it's really interesting to it's
really interesting to think about
and i think another key piece to this um
which i don't have answers to but but
there is an element of emotion and rage
in the physical violence versus again
more of that clinical
you know information warfare and so um
it's really easy
to show a battlefield
where there's death on both sides and
bombs being dropped and buildings
destroyed
it fits very well into propaganda for
everyone involved
right regardless of what side they're on
when you start talking about
cyber warfare how many times have we
seen a big company get
data hacked or information hacked and we
all you know read the headlines maybe
throw a tweet out and then move on with
our day and don't remember it anymore
and so it's just very very different i
think uh
in the emotion and response that it
invokes in people when they hear about
it as well
you